this is a print showing San Francisco
Harbor in 1848 there's a little
smattering of houses and a few boats in
the water
it looks pretty peaceful and it was San
Francisco only had about a thousand
residents and California had only newly
become a u.s. territory at the close of
the a mexican-american war and this is a
photograph of San Francisco Harbor in
1850 the water is crowded with ships and
the land is crowded with houses less
than two years later San Francisco had
30,000 residents mainly young men who
had come from all over the world making
the city perhaps the most culturally
diverse place on earth at that time
period what happened the short answer is
Gold in January 1848 gold was discovered
in California near the Sierra Nevada
mountains right about here
San Francisco was the Gateway to that
gold the nearest harbor were ships could
land with prospective gold miners from
the East Coast Europe South America and
Asia before the Gold Rush the non-indian
population of the state of California
was about fifteen thousand people by
1860 it was more than three hundred and
fifty thousand and in the same time
period the Native American population
decreased from a hundred and fifty
thousand to only thirty thousand the
Gold Rush and its impact on California
is one very dramatic illustration of the
causes and effects of westward migration
in the years surrounding the Civil War
this drive to expand the United States
west to the Pacific is often called
manifest destiny
based on a phrase that was coined by New
York journalist John O'Sullivan who
wrote in 1845 that westward expansion
would be the fulfillment of our Manifest
Destiny to overspread the continent
allotted by Providence for the free
development of our yearly multiplying
Millions the word manifest in this sense
means clear or obvious
Providence is another word for God's
help so O'Sullivan was saying that God
had provided the continent for the
United States to expand and it was
obviously the destiny of the United
States to do so but despite the
prevailing idea that the American West
was an empty land full of limitless
resources there were in fact a lot of
Native people already living in the West
and the arrival of people not only from
the East Coast but from all over the
world in the second half of the 19th
century would have enormous effects on
both people and politics so let's start
by talking about what drew immigrants to
the West in this era first and foremost
they were drawn by economic
opportunities available in the West
before there were gold miners flooding
San Francisco most people who went to
the West were farmers as land became
scarce ER in the East a trickle of
farming families headed to the Fertile
Willamette Valley of Oregon through the
Oregon Trail after the discovery of gold
in California and later in Montana
westward migration increased
exponentially but only a few miners
actually struck it rich mainly those who
were already in the area before gold was
discovered mining and farming weren't
the only economic opportunities
available in the West many people found
work in the industries that serve the
miners like hardware stores boarding
houses and restaurants there was also
the railroad between 1860 and 1880 the
miles of railroad track in the United
States tripled and as the railroad
expanded so did opportunities for work
on the railroad the expansion of the
railroad was one way that the federal
government facilitated westward
migration in 1862 in the midst of the
Civil War Congress passed the Pacific
Railway Act which granted railroad
companies more than a hundred million
acres in order to complete a
Transcontinental Railroad which they did
in 1869 the Transcontinental Railroad
reduced the time it took to get across
the country from five months to just six
days which made traveling and
transporting goods to
and from the West much easier in 1862
Congress also passed the Homestead Act
which granted 160 acres of land for free
to anyone over the age of 21 who had
never taken up arms against the US
government so no one who was affiliated
with the Confederacy as long as they
made improvements to the land within
five years and this included women
immigrants and African Americans the
Homestead Act was the wartime extension
of the ideas of the Free Soil movement
to populate Western lands with small
independent farmers rather than
slaveholders on giant plantations more
than 1.5 million people acquired land
this way the last reason that Americans
headed west that we'll talk about here
was cultural messaging of the time
period I mentioned earlier this notion
of manifest destiny that the United
States had a divine mission to spread
across North America closely related to
that was a widespread belief among
whites that American civilization was
superior to other cultures and that any
barriers to us expansion like Native
Americans and Mexican Americans who
possess the land onto which settlers
flooded were obstacles to progress and
civilization this painting which was
painted in 1872 by the artist John ghast
is called American Progress in it you
can see an allegorical figure of America
holding a schoolbook and helping to lay
telegraph wire she brings with her
symbols of American civilization
railroads and covered wagons and farmers
with log cabins and she drives away
symbols of what the artist portrays as
wilderness or savagery Native Americans
Buffalo even an angry bear down here you
can even see how the artist painted the
right side of the painting with a bright
clear sky and the left side with dark
shadows and clouds so that this central
figure of America seems to be driving
out the darkness encourage you to pause
the video and see how many symbols of
civilization
symbols of wilderness you can identify
in this painting now that we've
discussed the causes of westward
expansion let's talk about some of its
effects a major one is an increase in
sectional conflict as new western states
join the Union it inflamed tensions over
the balance of power between free and
slave states in Congress which
ultimately would lead to the Civil War
another effect was an increase in racial
conflict in the West as people from all
over the world came to the west and
competed for land and gold there was a
surge in racial violence before and
after the Civil War as white settlers
crowded onto the lands of Plains Indians
US Army sought to exterminate them or
confine them to reservations in
California white miners sought to expel
foreign miners
and Native Americans from regions with
gold vigilantes killed or expelled 80%
of the native population of the region
in just over a decade also in California
vigilante groups attacked Chinese
communities and even tried to destroy
Chinatown in San Francisco in 1877 the
state government in California also
imposed high taxes on foreign miners
especially the Chinese these
discriminatory laws would lay the
groundwork for the first race based
immigration restriction in US history
the Chinese Exclusion Act of 1882 the
enormous increase in westward expansion
in this era led to unprecedented
prosperity for some an unprecedented
misery for others but in 1877 at the end
of the Reconstruction era the process of
westward expansion was not yet complete
many of the political social and
economic consequences of the events in
this time period would become even more
pronounced in the last years of the 19th
century